this is the new urban decay vice lip  bond glossy liquid lipstick this is  extremely pigmented i was really  impressed by the color but i feel like  it wasn't as shiny as i thought it would  be i let it dry down for 10 minutes and  kiss the back of my hand to see if it  transferred at all and it did but only a  little bit and the lipstick still looked  good i was really excited to try out  this rem beauty sweetener concealer i  scooped some up and just warmed it on  the back of my hand and the concealer  looks thicker than it feels i was  actually surprised at how lightweight it  felt when i was blending it out the  coverage with this is amazing these nyx  ultimate glow shots look so pretty that  i literally bought three of them the  pigment on some is better than others  but overall i would say the pigment  isn't great with these on their own i  had to build them up a lot to get them  to look like this